welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
boss and this is a breakdown of hawkeye
episode two and uh are we looking at two
hawkeyes or is there an echo in here i'm
sorry please don't click away this
episode was filled with marvel easter
eggs and interesting visual details and
clues for what could be coming next in
this murder mystery so i'm gonna break
it down scene by scene where everything
you might have missed and a reminder
that you can get our new limited edition
merch design inspired by hawkeye at
newrockstarsmerch.com and if you get
this latest obsession you'll get the
added bonus option of writing in a
custom shout out for our hawkeye inside
marvel after show the episode opens with
clint and kate kate still in shock from
the tracksuit attack and seeing arman's
corpse but clint keeps a level head
evoking that same reassuring energy that
he showed a similarly panicked wanda
maximoff back in age of ultron the city
is flying we're fighting an army of
robots
and i have a bow and arrow none of this
makes sense but if you step out that
door
you are an avenger marvel head kevin
feige actually said that that moment
back then was what convinced him to
greenlight this hawkeye series the
hawkeye title logo is taken directly
from the title design of the fraction
aha comics here you can see an arrow
bullseye in the a followed by a shorter
arrow hitting the same exact spot oh the
big one's clint the little one's k just
showing how both of them are essentially
the world's greatest archer clint
escorts kate back to her place above
herman's hearty slice now in the comics
it was clint who lives in a crummy flat
but this series has reversed it to put
kate in this setup and we get a better
look at this apartment which is clearly
just the upstairs dining room of the
pizza shop with tables and chairs bolted
to the floor and on one table she even
left the salt and pepper shakers on it
nice place for a kid yeah i inherited it
are you 18.
i'm 22. yeah same thing now who would
kate have inherited this from maybe it
was one of the few joints that derek
still had the muscle to shake down or
maybe he had a legit pizza side business
better ingredients better pizza papa d
i've had over 40 pizzas in the last 30
days and clint thinks the ages of 18 and
22 are essentially the same thing but
also when you consider that this is a
world where a five-year blip occurred 18
year olds who dusted should be 23 and
when he got teenagers like flash
claiming to be drinking age you just
can't really trust these kids by the way
if kate bishop is 22 now in the year
2024 that would make her 10 years old
back in 2012 meaning she must have
survived the snap making her a fellow
blip survivor like clint which would
probably have hardened her made her more
self-reliant and if you think about it
this is the first marvel disney plus
series to focus on two characters who
both had to live through those five
years an apartment gate also has a
poster in french for fencing competition
with the design using the same kind of
impact line pattern similar to the
series target logo it's not just archery
she has to be super accurate for it's
everything now as kate comes back
downstairs notice the dog yeah doggo
runs upstairs it might be because he
senses trouble brewing outside he's not
the kind of dog that barks as clint
noticed when he walked in and that same
jerk who kicked him in the face is
outside and the doggy might smell his
axe body spray now when they throw
additional molotov cocktails clint
smartly breaks the window first so the
bottle won't explode on the pain which
allows him to catch it and volley it
this is similar to a move natasha made
in winter soldier when she shot out the
window glass first so that there would
be less damage when something goes
through it in this case her own body
kate responds by shooting through the
other flaming molotov in the guy's hand
which if you think about it returns the
favor from when she was holding a bottle
in her hand and they shot it out last
episode then she shoots a fire
extinguisher and even though this was
probably unintentional it totally
ricochets off the bullseye on her target
they pick up some avengers supplies of
neosporin let me guess we're going to
your safe house
is it an avengers tower no
tommy sold that
a few years ago
that is so sad on so many levels we did
see a peek of the former avengers tower
back in episode 1 and hopefully we'll
get some answers soon on who its new
occupants are in the past i've theorized
the fantastic four making this a new
baxter building but now i'm wondering it
could be whoever wanted that tony stark
watch because they're the kind of person
obsessed with collecting stark
memorabilia for now let's just assume
it's going to be kingpin because he's
he's going to be mephisto this series
everything's kingpin confirmed kate
takes them to the home of her aunt moira
brandon now in the west coast avenger
comics moira brandon was the name of a
movie star whose estate was turned into
the avengers compound that would explain
all the old movie posters decorating the
apartment including creature of a dark
galaxy starring moira brandon and luke
ballard who is a marvel visual design
artist probably the prop guy who made
this poster way to get your name in
there luke but on the buzzer of this
apartment are several names most of them
don't appear to refer to anyone specific
but there is a jones and gunther in 2e
maybe for jessica jones kate uses a
frozen pizza to ice her wound just like
how she ices her wounds with frozen
foods in the comic series including
actually a frozen pizza and a mug shot
kate took notes and doodled what she
could remember of the tracksuits joey
face is very white i kind of feel like
dwight true realizing i'm the pervert
pam
realizing a firefighter who took his
ronin suit is an nyc larper clint looks
them up on
instagram your costume looks pretty bad
and how about now you see me yeah
ah he said his name was grylls so in the
comic series grylls is one of clint's
neighbors who is named girls because he
grills on the roof he's one of many
tenants who end up standing up against
the criminals in the neighborhood
without saying too much i'm now a bit
worried for this guy since they had to
name him grylls clint is right
clint sends his kids home without him
and nate is learning sign language just
a little reminder early in this episode
of clint's hearing loss ahead of his
encounter with maya lopez ekko who is
deaf and that may be something that
connects these two characters now as
kate is watching the news blaming the
ronin for armand's murder the tv cuts to
a commercial for roger's the musical i
love how this musical is basically
becoming the triple dent gum of hawkeye
and once we flash to the title screen of
the six avengers silhouettes not only is
hawkeye small and in the background he's
actually nearly cropped out of the frame
as they go through times square kate
asks about clint's hearing aid and he
flashes back to the opening battle of
age of ultron his big jump in the battle
of new york as we saw in the opening
prologue scene of this series and thanos
blowing up avengers compound and end
game and when clint was able to catch
his breath in the rubble remember in
that moment clint was the only
non-powered human avenger with no armor
protection when the compound got bombed
roadie and scott had armor at least tony
didn't survive the battle everyone else
had superhuman enhancement so it just
makes sense that the surviving normal
humans would walk away from all this
with battle scars and i really really
like this character development for
clint someone has to bear the burden of
all this a kid runs past them to the
other costume characters
hey look that one's you no it's katniss
everdeen let's go aha so katniss
everdeen from the hunger games is now
mcu canon along with superman batman and
scooby-doo scooby-doo this crap notice
how there are two iron mans in two caps
a hulk a thor and an ant-man and as they
walk past them it looks like that iron
man slowly punches the cap's shield
almost like they're reenacting civil war
kate says the whole thing is that you're
low-key it's a very hard brand to sell i
mean being loki's not that hard of a
brand to sell sorry but she does go on
to say i think with all the scary stuff
that's happened since the avengers
appeared people don't want that
cynical cool thing anymore they want
sincerity yeah i can't help but see this
as a bit of meta commentary on earlier
marvel films like the avengers in which
joss whedon filled those scripts with
cynical cool dialogue a tone that the
mcu has gradually evolved over the years
with more sincere heartfelt moments kate
is suspicious of jack about armand's
death yeah tony dalton blinks a few
extra times here which you would think
is a sign of nervousness but i think
it's an on the nose sign of guilt that
he wants kate to read into just because
jack is so obviously someone who is
involved with armand's death and in
classic mystery structure you always
throw out a red herring character not
saying jack didn't kill armand i think
he's still the likely suspect i just
think there's more to the story and
right now he might be intentionally
attempting to keep kate's eyes on him so
as to keep her from digging deeper into
the real conspiracy behind the murder by
the way you are fully welcome to use
these kingpin theories to try to impress
your relatives during the holidays it
might work but when your grandma gets
bored you can impress her with your
knife skills with kamikoto knives
kamikoto makes great japanese steel
kitchen knives using traditional
techniques from japan their knives are
used by michelin star restaurants around
the world they only use premium steel
sourced from mills in japan and each
kamikoto knife is individually inspected
after a 19 step process which makes them
so confident in their knives that each
one comes with a lifetime guarantee each
knife comes in a beautiful ash wood box
that keeps the knife stored safely and
makes a kamikoto knife a great looking
gift and they offer a wide range of
japanese steel knives from big cleavers
down to steak knives and they have a
bunch of knife sets that would make
someone feel pretty special carving some
turkey or ham at the holiday table this
year now the nakiri knife feels
incredible in my hand and it looks
really cool and feels well balanced and
functional it's slicing and dyson time
kamikoto has a black friday sale going
on right now and on top of their sale
kamekoto is offering our viewers an
extra 50 off any purchase with discount
code nrs so head on over to kamikoto.com
nrs clint eventually tracks down the
larpers and he sees grylls trying to
impress someone by sliding his sword
across the back of his gauntlet the same
way clint cleaned the blood off his
blade in tokyo and end game i like how
all the characters in this universe
clearly just watched the mcu movies that
we watched like girls wasn't hanging out
in tokyo how would they know that's how
he cleaned its blade the dead serious
larper explains the live action role
plays yeah this whole thing if you think
about it she is making pretty much the
same point that kate was making clint's
participation in the avengers has been
kind of a larp on a higher stage and of
all them he's been the least willing to
embrace the whole performative aspect
she points out how most of the larpers
are firefighters and cops the first
responders tasked with keeping people
safe like clint is but these guys are
willing to let their inner nerds shine
and that's what clint has to do so he
lets grills fake kill him and i thought
thanos i think it's interesting for
clint to say it like that because while
he was certainly there for the battle of
earth we never actually saw him fighting
thanos one on one in that battle like he
wasn't in the opening charge he was kind
of on a side mission to play keep away
with the start gauntlet but there was
one deleted scene in end game that would
have shown clint and natasha engaging
thanos forces directly on vormir as they
hustled to get off the cliff i think i
would have liked that version better
honestly but despite clint telling her
not to contact him unless of an
emergency kate immediately attacks him a
whole bunch of times reminding us of
peter parker's multiple unanswered text
to happy hogan in homecoming and kate
gets a call from detective cottle
another character from the fraction
comics a santa monica detective whom
kate tells to arrest flint ward a jerk
who burns down a flower shop and then
gets sprung free by madame mask a
villain who many of us think eleanor
bishop could be revealed to be in the
series during the larp duel clint
refuses to drink the invisible potion
which i assume will be revealed to be
andrew garfield spider-man when no way
home comes out also let's remember
drinking a potion before a duel is what
happens in black panther at warrior
falls but in that case it depowers them
and speaking to black panther right
before the duel clint had said to grylls
i don't care just as t'challa said to
clint when they met in battle and civil
war
i'm clinch i don't care and then clint
has this tense exchange with grylls
much like the seriousness he showed when
he wanted natasha to let him give up his
life but like natasha grylls is really
the one we have to worry about here
clint stashes the suit in a gym locker
and calls his wife laura let me hang on
to it for insurance at least until i
clear things up with the old track suit
friends
jesus not those idiots i'm not sure how
high goes up so it's going to stick
around a little bit longer what's the
play a little catch release
nice one of nat's old moves yeah it's
always interesting how plugged in laura
is to clint's tactics and his mission
i've always wondered if marvel could
plan to reveal her as a retired
mockingbird not necessarily retconning
the character bobby morris in the comics
who also appeared in agents of shield
but like black widow or captain america
mockingbird could be kind of a legacy
title that's passed down among different
people also we get another hint from
clint that we are not sure how high this
goes implying a kind of criminal
hierarchy that may go all the way up to
a king pin and catch and release being
one of nat's old moves recalls the 2012
avengers film when she allowed herself
to be tied to a chair by her captives
that she was actually truly targeting
kate challenges jack to a casual round
of after dinner fencing as one does
honey be careful
when am i not careful i was talking to
jack eleanor wine in hand doesn't really
object that much to freaking swordplay
in a confined room just getting some
major emperor palpatine vibes from this
one doing afterward eleanor assures kate
that everything will be okay but we know
what comes next for you right you'll
graduate and in the fall you'll start
working at bishop security for real
right like we've always planned like
you've always planned yeah really seems
like eleanor has groomed kate to be her
own personal weapon and potentially
assassin in her shady security company
jack jokes it's not the first time
somebody tried to take my head off yeah
we don't see eleanor's expression but uh
i have a few follow-ups like who tried
to decapitate you and was it eleanor
armand echo or kingpin and will you get
beheaded by the end of the season
because that's not what i'm expecting
and he offers kate and armond the third
butterscotch just like the ones from the
bull in arman's home which again just
seems like a bit too obvious of a
smoking gun something he probably knows
will trigger kate echoing his risotto
metaphor earlier about agitating it to
just the right amount so i wouldn't be
surprised if this is a red herring both
for kate and for us and jack is
intentionally calling attention to
himself to keep kate from asking who
else was involved with arman's murder
kate uses a bishop security app to track
clint using his phone number an app that
seems a bit suspicious for them to even
have her login is bishop 11 2012 which
could be for november 20th 2012 or just
the month of november 2012 which in
current mcu history nothing really major
happens other than it would be six
months after the battle of new york and
might be when eleanor bishop launched
the company and created this account for
kate and in real life history november
21st 2012 was the publishing date of the
fourth issue of the series this show is
based on in which shield assigns clint
to retrieve the incriminating tape from
the auction now i did try to figure out
what password she's typing in it is very
much a random string of numbers from
haley steinfeld just tapping the screen
in the insert and then they later be
affects all the dots coming in like at
one point like none of her fingers are
tapping anything and dots are still
coming in but clint's phone number is
two and two one eight eight three five
two two they didn't do it five five five
i did try to call it it was a
disconnected number but it is a new york
city area code which is interesting
meaning clint must have kept his number
while working with the avengers out of
new york despite living the past several
years in missouri clint tries to
smooth-talk the tracksuits including
qazi the clown who seems like their boss
but they mentioned she wants him alive
and kate drops in making both of them
hostages and the tracksuits report this
to their boss
we have
them
ah yes alacox is playing maya lopez aka
echo the native american deaf vigilante
in the comics with connections to
kingpin and confirmed now to be getting
her own spin-off series on disney plus
but what does she want with kate and
clint well it seems like most characters
of this world still don't yet know that
clint was the ronin himself but at the
very least this gang suspects that clint
and kate are at least associated with
the ronin figure now in addition to the
ronin making enemies with all of
organized crime as we learned from the
auctioneer last episode there was that
one detail from avengers end game that
rhodey mentioned of the ronan
slaughtering a cartel in mexico so maya
lopez could have had a relative or
associate in that group that clint
killed and now ronan has been on her
vengeance list but either way everyone
in new york's organized crime operations
hates the ronin and these two are
obviously associated with him now the
character of echo in the comics says
photographic reflexes abilities similar
to taskmaster and on inside marvel mt
theorized that introducing echo in this
red lit room could be a clue to her past
perhaps as one of the liberated widow
agents of the kgb red room in black
widow remember the mcu has suggested
that these widow agents have spread far
and wide after those events and one of
them reappeared in the background of
sheng chi telling us that widows could
end up in all sorts of places of the
criminal underworld of the mcu now in
the black widow film hundreds of women's
faces flashed across the screen showing
that there were widows all around the
world there was one of them who we
thought looked a bit similar to alaqua
cox though the nose is different but the
implication could still be the same they
could give echo a new backstory as an
ex-widow that would help explain her
taskmaster-esque fighting skills and
could tie her into the backstory of
clint's late friend natasha as well as
elena bulova whom we know will cross
over into the series after being tasked
by val to hunt clint down in the black
widow post-credits scene so is echo the
ultimate boss that the tracksuit mafia
works for well i don't think the top
boss would need to be on site like this
that's never how it works so my guess is
that echo reports to someone that
someone could be eleanor or jack maybe
even val maybe even kingpin because
there's always a bigger fisk
but one last detail during the animated
end credit sequence we see some coins
being flung at bottles and one gets
smashed in the comics clint's brother
barney aka trick shot taught him how to
aim coins at bottles just like this to
support this channel check out our great
merch options at new rockstarsmerch.com
follow me on instagram and twitter at
eavos follow new rockstars subscribe to
new rocks for some more analysis and
breakdowns of everything marvel thanks
for watching bye
[Music]
you